now I think it was a problem this is why
I and um if you have gone from this as a
basis you have inherited this problem
okay on this is a very clever way thumbs
up in terms of ingenuity for how to get
tea but there's a problem and I'll show
you what the problem is by appealing to
the first equation I'm trying to walk
you through why this is actually a bad
idea you not just say it don't do it
but why by appealing to this the first
equation you've got now mass and gravity
involved right now mass and gravity are
both constants right so when you put
this into this you just get more of a
mess the more the further you try and go
with equation 1 the more it explodes you
get ya square root so you get like
height involved you get some other
unknown doesn't help okay so here's what
I'm gonna do I'm just gonna focus on
this equation here equation 1 not health
regen to be more useful now what's the
problem with the equation 2
well the problem I had with this was
that there's a theater in there and I
don't want the theater there so here's
the theater how do I get rid of it
well if I know what sine theta is I can
just shove it out for something else
that I do know and in triangle COP
theatres right there and I have all
these other things not H I don't know
anything but about these two that I do
know right so in this triangle sine
theta
Sakina is opposite over hypotenuse okay
with that
so now I'm gonna take this and well I
suppose
it doesn't matter Billy I'm gonna stop
this into equation 2
okay watch what happens right are its T
times R on L okay I can divide both
sides by ah and then I can multiply by
so I would like to argue I think this is
a bit simpler okay but you can see you
see why why do you go in this direction
this direction rather than this
direction ingenious as it is you start
to add in things which which cloud the
cachaça all right so you go kitchen
thumbs up how do I get this angle now
now this time this time both of these
equations are going to be more useful to
us okay because they both involve from
the feet up okay and don't forget now I
know what the tension is so I can use
this have a look at equation two and one
what's the easiest way to get this
unknown out of it but keep the theta I
think I should divide right adding
subtracting you're still gonna have the
T there so I'm going to divide
suggestions which way should I divide
two divided by one okay so this is um
happy now okay so your T's are gonna
cancel sine theta and cos theta just
gives you tan
okay you even don't have to worry about
mass anymore okay so you're gonna get
all up there maybe swear on G so I just
wanna be able yeah don't fill out just
like all right now last little bit see
how do I work out this height how do I
work it out well with all of this
information right we've got we've got
plenty of easy ways to get there okay so
poorly now that we know that 10 is equal
to this right 10 Peter will give me a
ratio between these two sides right so
back in this triangle and see curvy
right what's 10 Theo equal to its
opposite over hypotenuse which is ah
over sorry opposite under Jason
rnh yes so there's that height that I
marked up I know what 10 theater is
there it is
Omega squared or ROH I can divide
through by arc is not zero that's all
good and so now I just take the
reciprocal H is equal to
okay sir kids that summer and let's see
what to do school about this one two
three okay because they're not just
equations that are just hanging me there
they tell you useful field tell me this
one
tension what does it depend on it
depends on three things
mass and length well those are constants
no big deal it depends on Omega as well
so the far start and you guys can
experience this if you have like a
necklace or some other more budget you
don't mind spinning okay the faster you
spin it right the more tension you feel
it tugging on your finger right so as
Omega increases angular velocity tension
increases it pulls on you more let's
have a look at this next one in the same
way you know RG constant no big deal but
Omega as angular velocity increases what
happens to the angle right that's why
this angle it's up here isn't it right
it moves from going just kind of small
right it's a small feet up yeah
so as I increase angular velocity it
gets a really really large theta I'm
preaching off to file to I guess last it
what happens with that increased omega
here because that's the only other
useful thing you can do increase omega
this is high
ah like this T right so as I increase
angular velocity this gets compressed
right which you can see you can see it
look see it starts to approach up toward
the fixed point where everything is
suspended from okay so you can see all
of these things when you understand how
the equations interact with each other
and change as you modify some of the
variables that make sense